[Música]
[Aplausos]
se han puesto a pensar porque andamos
por la vida tan apurados
como hemos apurados dormimos poco porque
el otro día tenemos que hacer un montón
de cosas nos juntamos con nuestros
amigos diciéndole no para tengo cinco
minutitos nada más para estar con vos
hacemos zapping permanentemente en la
tele
manejamos como locos que nos pasen un
ritmo frenético
vamos a explotar algún día
con el problema todo esto
los economistas decimos yo soy
economista economista de la conducta
los economistas decimos que los seres
humanos preferimos recompensas en el
corto plazo antes que en el largo plazo
traducido en palabras fáciles que
significa preferimos pocos ya a mucho si
hay que esperar
ustedes creían que los seres humanos
somos racionales
más o menos preferimos poco ya
no voy a hacer un pequeño test de
ansiedad esto nos conecta con la
ansiedad pues si preferimos todo ya con
muchas cosas ya eso nos conecta con la
ansiedad yo le voy a hacer un pequeño
test a ver levanten la mano aquellos que
cada cinco minutos durante su mano
derecha aquellos que cada cinco minutos
están consultando el teléfono
u
más de la mitad
levante manu izquierda aquellos que
entre 5 y 15 minutos
yo me incluyo
bueno casi todo el resto
y levanten las dos manos aquellos que
como mi mamá que tiene 70 años y
entiende poco de tecnología son capaces
de aguantar media hora una hora dos
horas o toda una tarde a que suene el
teléfono muy bien hay algunos hay
algunos muy bien
hay algunos países que han levantado las
manos dos veces
bueno
tampoco lo quería reprender por esto es
sólo un síntoma ansiedad vivimos
acelerados hay muchos síntomas de la
aceleración en la que estamos viviendo
y esto no tiene nada de malo per se y lo
que quiero decir con esto el ser humano
está preparado para tomar decisiones
rápidas el premio nobel de economía
daniel kahneman que psicólogo no
economista
economista de la conducta igual que yo
él dice que los seres humanos tenemos un
sistema rápido de toma de decisiones y
un sistema lento de toma de decisiones
el sistema rápido de decisiones es algo
que hemos heredado de nuestros ancestros
evolutivos del hombre prehistórico que
tenía que luchar contra la amenaza de
los animales salvajes de la naturaleza
y eso lo hemos generado en nuestro
cerebro no es muy diferente de si bien
la corteza cerebral ha evolucionado el
sistema límbico no es muy diferente el
hombre prehistórico
por lo tanto estamos preparados para
tomar decisiones rápidas apuradas
emocionales sesgadas rápidas las que nos
permiten salir del paso
y hasta ahí está todo bien siempre ha
sido así pero cuál es la cuestión
en los últimos yo diría 10-15 años ha
habido una aceleración de esa toma de
decisiones rápidas aceleradas por una
serie de razones que se las voy a pasar
a describir ahora pero antes les comento
por si ustedes no sabían
los seres humanos tomamos entre 1.000 y
2.500 decisiones por día
ustedes dirán pero cuando donde como sí
eso incluye las decisiones rutinarias
lavarse los dientes atarse los cordones
y manejar manejar el rutinario pero
también incluye toda una serie de
decisiones que las meditamos poco
aproximadamente se calcula que el 90% de
esas entre 1.000 y 2.500 decisiones las
tomamos con el sistema rápido y un 10%
con el sistema lento
qué es lo que yo veo y muchos estudiosos
si me puedo incluir entre los estudiosos
vemos o observamos observamos que ese
10% de decisiones reflexivas lentas
meditadas en parte se están pasando al
90 por ciento de decisiones rápidas poco
reflexionadas emocionales intuitivas
cuál es el problema de esto que cada vez
pensamos menos y cada vez actuamos más
rápido más sin pensar o pensando muy
poco
ustedes han pero bueno qué es lo que
está pasando en esto bueno este es el
corazón de mi charla
hay por lo menos dos razones del
contexto actual que nos están llevando a
que cada vez tenemos más decisiones con
el sistema rápido y no con el sistema
reflexivo cuáles son en primer lugar
el mundo físico el mundo como lo
conocíamos el mundo de las relaciones
interpersonales como lo conocíamos hasta
hace 10 15 20 años se ha virtualizado
el mundo físico el de las relaciones ha
pasado a estar acá
acá no puedo estar mis dos hijos pero
esperen que la cordà
ahí está
el de las aplicaciones
las aplicaciones para paquetes
turísticos las aplicaciones para citas
fíjense lo más humano
que hay que es conocerse con otra
persona está acá hay un montón de gente
probablemente muchos de ustedes hayan
conocido a su pareja a través de acá
hay cientos miles millones de
aplicaciones para cada una de las
necesidades que antes satisfacemos por
el mundo físico que quiero decir con
esto
antes cuando nosotros por ejemplo
queríamos contratar un paquete turístico
que hacíamos utilizábamos algún medio de
transporte llegábamos hasta la agencia
de turismo intercambiamos opiniones o
información con con la asesora turística
y nos decía si te conviene viajar acá te
sale te sale
ahora no lo hacemos todo por alguna de
las 456 aplicaciones de moda que hay en
materia turística y terminamos hasta
emitiendo el ticket de vuelo no
necesitamos ya ni siquiera imprimir el
pasaje porque vamos y lo pasamos en en
el aeropuerto por el código qr y todo
virtual
con los bancos lo mismo todo por home
banking ahora con las citas lo mismo
chateo en algún momento se termina
conociendo claro pero
todo eso se ha virtualizado qué tiene de
malo esto no no es que tenga algo de
malo es que cambia nuestra manera de
tomar decisiones porque porque en
nuestro teléfono ahora todo está a un
click de distancia
yo no tengo que ir a ningún lado
tanto de un clic de distancia eso
fomenta la ansiedad y fomenta la
decisión rápida porque porque me están
mandando notificaciones permanentemente
esas aplicaciones si yo la bajé a mi
teléfono es porque me interesan y por lo
tanto estoy en el trabajo y las tengo
abiertas
eso es reseñar multi tasking multitarea
yo estoy trabajando y estoy con el
teléfono con todas las aplicaciones
abiertas y me están mandando
notificaciones permanentemente y estoy
generando más emociones permanentemente
esa es una de las causas que está
generando que tomemos decisiones
apuradas
en segundo lugar y más importante
todavía las grandes corporaciones las
grandes marcas han aprendido a hacer
marketing en serio
sí como les digo marketing en serio
siempre fueron buenas para vender las
grandes empresas eso está claro
eso está claro siempre nos han vendido
los que han querido pero ahora realmente
es tremendo la facilidad que tienen con
el auge del neuromarketing o el
marketing de las emociones o todo esto
que ha permitido entender cómo se puede
estimular al cerebro las grandes
corporaciones las grandes marcas saben
qué colores qué olores qué sabores que
diseño del producto pueden darle para
que la gente rápidamente vaya y diga lo
quiero lo quiero no quiero no quiero
sale 10 pagó 15
no tengo los 15 los sacó la tarjeta de
crédito no me alcanza con la tarjeta de
crédito en deuda de hipnotizar
te hipnotiza
eso no está ni bien ni mal es
son cuestiones que permiten la
tecnología los conocimientos los avances
científicos
están permitiendo vuelvo a repetir tanto
que el mundo físico se ha virtualizado y
esté todo un clic de distancia como el
marketing de las grandes corporaciones
están permitiendo que
la gente decida cada vez más rápido
decía cada vez más rápido y por lo tanto
decisiones que antes las reflexionaba un
poco más ahora las tomas
en muy poquito tiempo
pero vuelvo a repetir que muchos de
ustedes me dirán cuál es el problema con
esto
es más
yo porque soy un
de 40 para arriba generación
y que se llama
perdón generación x pero tan los
millennials es una generación y la
generación z que son los chiquitos
nuestros hijos que ya se han criado de
esa manera entonces me van a decir bueno
y cuál es el problema con esto
el problema es que la gente que no
estaba acostumbrado a esto
lo siente porque lo siente
porque estaba acostumbrada a reflexionar
determinadas decisiones un poco más y
porque estaba acostumbrado a llevar un
ritmo de vida relativamente reflexiva en
algunos aspectos pero ahora con esta
aceleración tan grande que hay y esta
posibilidad que tienen las empresas de
crearnos deseos permanentemente
hipnotizarnos con este marketing de las
emociones para que deseemos esos
productos y vayamos rápido a comprarlos
y paguemos lo que hay que pagar nos
están generando un proceso de
insatisfacción o angustia aquellos que
no pueden llegar a todo lo que quieren
satisfacer
una angustia tanto por una cuestión de
dinero que no alcanza o de tiempo
el tiempo dinero si el día tuviera 36
horas en 24 horas nuestros salarios
podrían ser un 50% más altos y podríamos
comprar más por eso andamos tan apurados
en parte
porque queremos comprimir el tiempo para
sacarle el máximo de utilidad y poder
ganar más dinero para satisfacer más
deseos de todos los que
las grandes corporaciones están
intentando generarnos
para que deseamos rápido por el
marketing de las emociones
esto no es ni bueno ni malo vuelvo a
repetir es los avances tecnológicos sean
han habido miles de disrupciones
tecnológicas en la historia de la
humanidad y la gente se adapta darwin
supervivencia al más apto
no queda otra lo que yo le vengo a
contar y le vengo a aconsejar un poco es
cómo hacer para adaptarnos a este mundo
acelerado el mundo desaceleró el cambio
de lass aceleró todo está un clic de
distancia
nos van a generar deseos permanentemente
y lo vamos a querer satisfacer eso está
no lo podemos cambiar lo que sí podemos
cambiar es la actitud nuestra
a qué me refiero con la actitud nuestra
la manera de encarar esa situación
en primer lugar para super para que las
personas que por ahí realmente han caído
en cuestiones de angustia y depresión
le pasó un número nomás hay una pandemia
moderna que se llama trastorno de
ansiedad o ataques de pánico
tres de cada diez personas en el mundo
lo sufren
entre otras cosas por andar demasiado
acelerados en la vida
yo mismo lo he padecido ese problema ojo
te pueda dar por otras cuestiones
también te puede por depresiones te
puede dar por cuestiones con algún
familiar querido pero también te puede
dar por vivir demasiado acelerado al
mismo día por eso
yo sé lo que es tener trastorno de
ansiedad sé lo que es caminar por la
calle por al lado una pared
por miedo que te dé un bobazo
con una se ve que no te da
porque es lo que tiene el ataque de
pánico
en mentira que te daré un simulacro de
fusilamiento que te hace el cerebro no
te da nada lo que es una depresión es
una
para decirlo en términos más técnicos es
una descompensación del sistema de
alerta que tenemos internamente los
seres humanos tenemos un sistema de
alerta que nos alerta básicamente sin
querer ser redundante ante el peligro
cuando tenés ataques de pánico tras
terna ansiedad se te desequilibra eso y
por lo tanto sentís alerta cuando no
tenéis que sentir alerta
eso es lo que sucede cuando a mí me
sucedió yo no sufrir ningún problema de
depresión ni nada relacionado con lo
emocional profundo familiar afectivo yo
lo que tuve un problema de que andaba
demasiado acelerado y medio eso
pero no no el objeto de esta charla
hablar de los ataques de pánico se los
comento como una anécdota me a esta
situación de andar de andar acelerado
te puede generar estrés agudo y eso se
está viendo hoy en día en las clínicas
de psicólogos y psiquiatras hay un gran
aumento del consumo de ansiolíticos y
antidepresivos
no estaba bueno eso
y eso es un poco lo que yo quiero tratar
de aconsejarles cómo hacer para no
llegar a esos extremos
hay dos consejos que después humildes
consejos que les puedo dar uno el del
bombero que apaga el fuego
el otro en una solución más de fondo
pero la el bombero también es importante
porque para tratar de evitar llegar a
situaciones demasiado
y angustiantes y de ansiedad
cuando uno se va poniendo ansioso
se le empieza primero endurece el cuello
se empiezan a contraer los maxilares uno
se va dando cuenta de esto empieza a
sentir puntadas en el pecho algunas en
la panza también pero más que nada
apuntada en el pecho
es el momento de apagar el celular
apagado desconectar los media hora
parate te vas a un baño en todos los
lugares de acabar un baño
te vas al baño párate frente al espejo
respira profundo evitar llegar a
situaciones de ansiedad de descontrol
que el multitasking multitarea te lleva
o el tránsito loco o el hecho de querer
hacer demasiadas cosas a la vez
te genera evitar llegar a esa situación
parece la situación del bombero vuelvo a
repetir la solución de fondo perdón otra
situación otra solución también otro
consejo para bajar los niveles de estrés
están todo lo que está de moda de auge
actualmente que es gimnasios yoga
meditación mindfulness
todo lo que sea de alguna manera genera
endorfinas genera relajación para paliar
un poco esta locura en la que vivimos
día a día pero bueno a repetir esas son
soluciones que apagan el fuego del
bombero eso no te va a dar la calma que
necesita a largo plazo de fondo la calma
que necesita de fondo la vas a lograr
haciendo el esfuerzo por auto conocerte
auto entenderte y darte cuenta a dónde
crees ir si cada uno de nosotros logra
someramente darse cuenta para dónde
quiere ir
no te van a volver loco con las grandes
marcas que te quieren vender todo a todo
precio que te generan deseos de todo
tipo para que satisfagan no te van a
volver loco todas las aplicaciones que
tienes abiertas en el teléfono y que
quieres ver las notificaciones de todos
por ahí pasa la clave por tranquilizarse
y lograr el sosiego que hoy muchos han
perdido por auto conocerse por auto
entenderse y ya que les hago una
comparación con el mundo del fútbol que
yo amo realmente
aprender a parar la pelota
como aquellos jugadores cerebrales de
los pocos que hay porque la mayoría
corren fútbol argentino se ha vuelto muy
de ida y vuelta pero todavía hay algunos
jugadores cerebrales que se atreven a
parar la pelota y en medio de un clásico
domingo con 50.000 personas gritándole
se pasa a la parada h hace esto hace
aquello esos jugadores cerebrales
aparecían y pisaba la pelota
y cuando todo le decía mete el pase para
no
las llevaban y las jugaban con un
lateral
con la jugada con el otro lateral
o se la tocan al defensor para atrás
pero no porque fueran timoratos y
miedosos y no quisieran decidir sino
porque estaban esperando el momento
justo
para meter el pase gol es equivale
justito ahí milimétrico para que el
delantero hiciera el gol que le estoy
diciendo con esto las 50.000 personas
esas gritando me en el costado pasar la
parada pasar la pelota son las 50.000
marcas y aplicaciones del teléfono que
me dicen comprar me compraban mí
paga lo que tenéis lo que no tenéis
el jugador reflexivo o el decidido
reflexivo lo que tiene que hacer es
decir nuevo para
yo soy el dueño
de esta jugada yo voy a decidir en qué
momento voy a meter el pase
y para eso nos tenemos que auto conocer
y auto entender y si no nos alcanza con
nosotros mismos están los psicólogos la
psicoterapia
no hay nada mejor que ir y charlar
conoció todas las obras sociales que
cubren un psicólogo
va a charlas con el psicólogo le decía
no sé lo que me pasa estoy ansioso estoy
angustiado lloro de noche me estoy
irritado con mi pareja
tenemos que aprender a auto entendernos
es la única manera de que vamos a poder
sobrellevar
este mundo loco este mundo acelerado en
el que estamos incluidos y que se va a
acelerar cada día más se va a acelerar
cada día más y eso no está ni bien ni
mal es bueno repetir es nos tenemos que
adaptar como darwin supervivencia del
más apto
tenemos que volvernos aptos para
sobrevivir y ser felices en este mundo
acelerado
por eso les dejo como frase final
atrevámonos a aprender a pisar la pelota
esta pelota que tengo acá
seamos nosotros dueño del partido no los
50 mil marcas y aplicaciones o hinchas
en el fútbol que nos dicen para donde
tenemos que ir nosotros tenemos que
aprender a saber ya decir a dónde
queremos ir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]